la pregunta que nos hacen es cuántos
estudiantes asistieron a la escuela
einstein en el 2006 y en esta tabla nos
dicen que en el 2001 asistieron 150
estudiantes en el 2002
asistieron 225 estudiantes y en el 2003
se tenían 300 pero si te das cuenta no
nos dicen cuántos estudiantes hay en el
2006 así que creo que quieren que veamos
el patrón de esta tabla y cuánto aumentó
el número de estudiantes cada año y con
esto podemos suponer que es el mismo
patrón que se va a conservar hasta el
año 2006 así que si nosotros logramos
averiguar cuál es el patrón de un año al
año siguiente entonces podemos
determinar la cantidad de estudiantes en
el 2004 y luego en el 2005 y luego en el
2006 y bueno la suposición que estamos
haciendo en este problema y que creo que
el problema quiere que hagamos es que
cualquiera que sea el patrón de
crecimiento en estos tres años este
mismo va a continuar hasta el 2006 así
que veamos qué es lo que sucede aquí
cuando damos un paso en este primer año
que pasa con la población de estudiantes
pues bueno pasamos de 150 a 225
estudiantes y la forma más fácil de
entender este patrón es cuántos
estudiantes aumentamos cada año por lo
tanto cuánto tenemos de 150 a 225 pues
aumentamos de 150 a 250 estudiantes y
para llegar a 225 hay que aumentar otros
25 estudiantes más así que por lo tanto
hemos aumentado 75 estudiantes y ahora
cuánto hay de 225 a 300 en cuántos
estudiantes hemos aumentado pues parece
que otra vez 75 estudiantes 75 más 225
es igual a 300 entonces parece que
aumentamos otros 75 estudiantes así que
el patrón es que cada año va a haber 75
estudiantes más que acudan a la escuela
a stein y bueno pues digamos con el
mismo patrón si sumamos otros 75
estudiantes
en el 2004 voy a tener 375 estudiantes
lo cual es 375
muy bien ahora en el 2005 si suponemos
que el patrón se mantiene
tenemos que sumar otros 75 estudiantes y
entonces que nos dan nos dará 450
estudiantes en el 2005 si suponemos que
patrón sigue y ya casi casi terminamos
si sumamos un último 75 para el 2006
entonces tengo 75 más 450 si suma 50 a
450 tienes 500 y con otros 25 vamos a
tener 525 estudiantes así que esa
debería de ser la respuesta a la
pregunta si asumimos que el patrón sigue
y se mantienen entonces en el año 2006
habrá 525 estudiantes en la escuela
einstein